javascript closures are functions that
can access values outside of their own
curly braces in order to call a function
in your code the javascript interpreter
needs to know about the function itself
and any other data from the surrounding
environment that it depends on
everything needs to be neatly closed up
into a box before it can be fed into the
machine
take for example a pure function that
only depends on its own arguments and
internal data
what we have here is a fully
self-contained closed expression
when it's called it gets pushed onto the
call stack where it's executed and its
internal data is only kept in memory
until it's popped back off the call
stack but what if that function
references data
outside of its own scope like from the
global environment or an outer function
that leaves us with an open expression
that references other
free variables throughout the
environment now in order for the
interpreter to call this function
and also know the value of these free
variables it creates a closure to store
them in a place in memory where they can
be accessed later
that area of memory is called the heap
and unlike the call stack which is
short-lived
it can keep data in memory indefinitely
then decide once you get rid of it later
with the garbage collector
so a closure is not just a function it's
a function combined with its outer state
or lexical environment as you might
imagine closures require more memory and
processing power than a pure function
but you'll come across many practical
reasons to use them
the most important one being data
encapsulation to prevent leaking or
exposing data where it's not needed we
can create a closure by defining an
outer function that contains the state
then an inner function that operates on
it the data contained here will not leak
out to the surrounding environment the
inner function has access to data
defined in the outer function scope but
the outer function does not have
access to the inner function in addition
many javascript apis are callback based
you can use closures to create a
function factory that takes an argument
then returns a brand new function which
can then be passed along to other
functions that expect a callback
this has been javascript closures in 100
seconds but stay tuned
because today we're going beyond 100
seconds to take a look at one of the
most famous javascript trick questions
that will wreck you on an interview if
you don't know closures but first make
sure to like and subscribe i'm trying to
fulfill my childhood dream of getting to
a million subscribers but it's going to
be really hard to get there
if you don't click the button just
kidding i have a ton of fun making these
videos and learn something new every
time
a great example of which is this tricky
javascript interview question the
question itself
is what does this code log out let's go
through it line by line
first we're declaring a variable i with
the var keyword
then a for loop that will run three
times by incrementing that variable
now inside the for loop is where
closures come into play we define a
function
log that console logs the global
variable i
this is not a pure function because it
depends on a variable outside of its
scope
therefore creating a closure then from
there we set up a timeout
and pass the log function as the
callback this queues up a task
to execute the log function after 100
milliseconds
so what do you think the output of this
code will be we're capturing the i
variable in the closure for each
iteration of the loop
so it would seem like it should log out
as 0 1 2.
but if we log it out it actually console
logs three three times
to understand why that happens we also
need to understand the difference
between
var and let when you use var in a for
loop
that variable actually gets hoisted up
into the parent scope which in this case
would be the global scope watch what
happens when we change the variable to
let
we get our original expectation of a
console log of 0 1
2. with var we have a global variable
that we're mutating over and over again
but with let we're creating a variable
that is scoped to the for loop in other
words
it's local to the for loop and can't be
accessed outside of it now remember
a closure is the combination of a
function and its lexical environment
in the case of let the closure is
capturing the log function
along with the variable i for each
iteration of the loop which would be 0 1
2. if we didn't have a closure here
javascript would allocate that i
variable in memory
in the call stack and then immediately
release it but because we do have a
closure
it stores that variable in the heap
memory so it can be referenced again
when that closure is called by the
timeout in the future
but when var is used it's capturing the
reference to the global variable
the reason it logs three three times is
because the timeout
doesn't run until 100 milliseconds later
long after that for loop has completed
and
iterated up to three we can actually
examine this behavior in the browser dev
tools by adding a debugger to the
closure
if you try to run this code in the
browser with the devtools open
it will take you to the sources tab and
allow you to inspect the call stack and
scope of the function
when lead is used you can see we have a
block scoped variable named i
but when var is used that variable is
now in the global scope
which changes the way it's captured by
the closure that's a pretty tricky one
but javascript interviewers love to ask
questions like this if you ever find
yourself faced with a question like this
the best thing you can do is talk
through the code slowly and explain how
a closure works
so they know you're on the right track
even if you don't come to the right
conclusion
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there thanks for watching and i will see
you
in the next one